[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the darker side of the
wizarding world
jk rowling and an old russian folktale
that very well
could have inspired voldemort's most
powerful weapon his horcruxes
this piece of folklore was actually
brought to my attention by subscriber
games x in a comment on one of my videos
last week
so games x if you're watching thank you
for the inspiration
because this video is centered around a
tale that inspired horcruxes
i'm going to very briefly introduce
horcruxes so that their properties are
top of mind
this should allow us to more easily
compare what we know to be horcruxes
and the horcrux-esque objects from
russian folklore
a horcrux is a dark object in which a
dark witch or wizard
has imbued part of their soul the
ultimate purpose of creating a horcrux
is to achieve immortality however the
truly sinister component of creating
horcrux
is that in order to produce one you must
murder someone
there are only two known wizards who
have created the horcrux
the first being herpet the fowl and the
second being voldemort
in harry potter very little is revealed
about the horcrux creation process
and all we can say for certain is that
murder is required
jk rowling who coined the term defines
it as follows
a receptacle prepared by dark magic in
which a dark wizard has intentionally
hidden a fragment of his soul
for the purpose of attaining immortality
furthermore
as exemplified by voldemort it is
possible for wizards to create more than
one horcrux
securing their immortality further by
encasing fragments of their soul
into multiple objects not only are
horcruxes hard to find
but they are also notoriously difficult
to destroy and it's for these reasons
that wizards who produce them
are able to claim immortality with such
certainty alright now you're refreshed
on horcruxes
however what you probably didn't know
was that the concept of a soul container
is not original to harry potter now it's
no secret that jk rowling drew all kinds
of inspiration
from all over the map when creating the
story there's
greek influence roman influence historic
literary influence
and well many other kinds of influence
evident within the harry potter story
and rolling certainly gives due credit
to the sources of inspiration
however when questioned specifically
about the origin of horcruxes
jk rowling claimed that nothing in
particular had inspired the concept
could this be the case certainly but
does the piece of russian folklore that
i'm about to tell you
seem quite familiar you be the judge the
piece of russian folklore in question
involves a figure named kosher the
deathless
and as you can probably tell by his name
he was someone that
like voldemort was able to cheat death
come to think of it
voldemort's name also alludes to his
immortality as
voldemort means flight of death koche
who also goes by the epithet the
immortal is an archetypal male
antagonist
that has been appearing in slavic tales
since before the 18th century
though he is mentioned across a
multitude of tales he is perhaps most
famous for a tale that surrounds his
evasion of death
for you see crochet much like voldemort
discovered a dark spell
that allowed him to separate soul from
body hiding his soul
inside of nested objects to protect it
the tale of koche
supports the idea in harry potter that
soul is the most important part of our
life force
and that the physical body is merely a
container a vessel
in order to prevent himself from being
killed kosher hides his soul inside of
nested objects
in order to protect it like the russian
matroyushka
doll or nesting doll there are layers
and layers that need to be peeled back
in order to get to the base layer each
layer acting
as one more measure of protection in
nicosia's tail
his soul is hidden within a needle
within an egg within a duck
and the kicker is that the duck flies
away whenever anyone tries to catch it
though kosher's method of soul
encasement differs from harry potter in
some ways
it's hard to ignore the parallels
between koche and voldemort
and i for one think that koche at least
subconsciously
if not consciously inspired rowling's
concept of the horcrux
what do you guys think let me know in
the comment section below
if you enjoy mythology and folklore in
general be sure to check out my
mythology channel mythology explained
which i'll link below until next time
greatness inspires envy
envy engenders spite spite spawns lies
[Music]
you